[Musique]
rien n'a été simple pour elle dans la
vie comme en politique mais mon invité a
tracé sa route franchit les obstacles un
à un pour siéger aujourd'hui à
l'Assemblée dans les rangs de la
[Musique]
majorité bonjour Fanta ber bonjour alors
s'il y a une chose qui vous agace en ce
sont les caricatures ou les généralités
que certains font parfois par exemple
considérrez que tous les députés
Renaissance dont vous faites parti sont
forcément issu de milieu favorisés on va
vous entendre répondre à vos collègues
de la France insoumise c'était fin
2022 sur les bancs de la majorité nous
ne sommes pas tous issus des classes que
vous décrivez ou plutôt que vous
haïssez comme vous aimez les prénoms moi
je suis la fille de Ibrahima et Mariam
ouvrier ouvrière retraité avec une
faible pension qui a été réévalué par
cette
majorité j'ai envie de vous dire que
vous ne représentez pas Ibrahima Mariam
et tous ceux avec qui j'ai grandi vous
êtes une bande de tikterss qui cherch le
buzz alors premier point visiblement
vous n'aimez pas les tiktokeerss si si
si j'adore TikTok en plus band de tiktur
non mais j'adore TikTok comme comme
comme une insulte non que ce que vous
avez voulu dire ce ce jour-là c'est quoi
c'est c'est que la gauche n'a pas
forcément le monopole du cœur le
monopole des classes populaires ouais je
pense que c'est ça c'est-à-dire que moi
je je j'ai tracé ma route et je viens de
cette classe là j'estime en plus parce
que mes parents ils sont toujours en
fait finalement que je les représente
dans chacun de mes choix et je pense que
tout ce que nous faisons en politique en
fait c'est pour les Français d'une
manière générale alors selon les textes
effectivement il va y avoir un angle qui
va être pris sur parfois une catégorie
de personnes mais la gauche aujourd'hui
surtout la gauche d'aujourd'hui ne peut
pas avoir le monopole et n'a pas le
monopole en fait alors dans cette prise
de parole vous évoquez donc vos parents
qui sont nés dans un village en Guinée
qui sont venus travailler en France qui
ont été ouvriers qui sont je crois donc
aujourd'hui à à la retraite vous avez
dit un jour que ils ont ils ont été au
RSA ils ont connu le RSA bien sûr nous
on a été élevé avec le système de
sociale finalement parce que mes parents
ont eu des trajectoires compliquées on
disait à l'époque donc que trp c'est
vrai qu'il ce sont des travailleurs
handicapés qui ont été exclus du du
système et c'est grâce finalement à tout
ce système que nous connaissons en
France que qu'ils ont pu élever quatre
enfants vous avez une trajectoire assez
rare exceptionnelle on peut le dire
qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce qu' l' a rendu
possible du côté de vos parents ils ont
dû faire des des sacrifices pour que
vous vos frères et sœurs puissiez faire
des études comment comment ça s'est
passé ouais je pense que c'était
vraiment important pour eux qu'on fasse
des études et moi j'ai pas été une bonne
élève au démarrage puisque j'ai du coup
je fais partie de cette génération qui
est allée en lycée professionnel et qui
est allée en lycée professionnel pas par
choix mais contraint et finalement ça
m'a amené aussi donc à retourner
finalement en lycée voilà dans ce lycée
général et puis ensuite à faire mes
études et obtenir un bac + 5 et à finir
à Science Po mais néanmoins depuis que
nous étions petit
mes parents font partie de ces personnes
qui ont toujours payé pour des cours
supplémentaires pour les mathématiques
pour le Français qui ont toujours pris
des il pay il payait des cours du soir
et ma mère faisait un chèque en fait à
la fin du mois en plus de toutes les
charges qu'elle avait à payer et il y a
cette ouverture vers la culture aussi
qui était importante pour eux
c'està-dire que ce soit au niveau du
sport ou des arts on a toujours pu
bénéficier d'un certain nombre
d'activités et ça je je les remercie
pour ça et du coup ça ça ça représente
quoi pour vous aujourd'hui d'être député
de la République française quand vous
vous retournez sur ce passé familial bah
c'est ben j'ai toujours les larmes aux
yeux parce qu'en
fait j'ai envie de vous dire je sais pas
c'est c'est toujours difficile d'en
parler non mais parce que ce sont les
gens qui nous voient comme députés
c'est-à-dire que moi je reste sans
tabérété donc voilà qui a grandit là où
elle a grandi mais c'est vrai que les
gens même s'ils sont en colère contre
les hommes et les femmes tique quand
vous allez quelque part et qu'on dit que
vous êtes député il y a ce regard un
petit peu d'admiration il y a ce voilà
ce questionnement et du coup c'est là
que vous vous rendez compte de ce que
vous représentez donc effectivement bah
il y en a 577 tous les 5 ans donc en
fait c'est une expérience incroyable
mais pour une personne comme moi jamais
j'aurais pu penser un jour m'assoir en
fait donc dans cet hémicycle al si on
parle un peu politique vous a vu sur le
projet de loi immigration signer cette
tribune transpartisane qui a fait la
Lune du journal Libération dans laquelle
vous réclamiez la régularisation des
travailleurs sans papier dans les
métiers dit
àention c'est votre histoire familiale
qui qui parle sur ce sujet- là précis
sur ce cette tribune il me paraissait
important d'arrêter l'hypocrisie
c'est-à-dire qu'aujourd'hui alors que ce
soit dans les grandes villes ou ailleurs
on a certain nombre de personnes qui
nous accompagnent dans notre quotidien
qui font des travaux pour nous qui
travaillent dans les cuisines de nos
restaurant qui gardent nos enfants qui
gardent nos aînés et je pense que le
temps est venu qu'on les regarde en face
et qu'on dise vous allez pouvoir
maintenant commencer une vraie vie parce
qu'en fait ce sont des vies qui sont
empêchées des gens qui travaillent des
heures et des heures qui n'ont pas de
reconnaissance du système et qui surtout
ne peuvent pas s'épanouir au sein de
notre République comme on voudrait qu'il
puisse le faire on va s'arrêter un peu
sur votre parcours d'engagement
politique vous avez commencé à vous
rapprocher de la politique en devenant
parents d'élèves de fil en aiguille vous
avez fini par vous présenter municipal à
Paris en 2014 sur une liste citoyenne
mais le coup d'accélérateur on va dire
pour vous ça a été 2016 le lancement
d'en marche par Emmanuel Macron
qu'est-ce qui vous a attiré dans le
projet politique d'Emmanuel Macron j'ai
écouteé j'étais déçu du quinquena de
François Hollande et je me disais vous
aviez voté socialiste jusqu'à prés ou
j'avais voté socialiste mon père me nous
demandait de c'é la consigne exactement
et donc et donc j'ai été happée par son
discours hein son discours la télé le
jour où il présente en marche et mon
ordinateur sur les genoux je suis dans
mon fauteuil rouge et en fait je
l'écoute au journal et c'est cette
notion je pense de déplacement
dépacement pour chacun d'entre nous et
donc ouais effectivement qui m'a percuté
et je trouvais qu'il avait vraiment
envie de transformer notre société et
donc aussi de de voilà de de vraiment
prendre en compte les enjeux
d'aujourd'hui et donc vous vous êtes
engagé en parallèle de votre carrière
professionnel dans le domaine des
ressources humaines très vite vous êtes
devenu la référente d'en marche sur le
15e arrondissement à Paris vous en avez
fait je crois la plus grosse structure
militante de Paris à à l'époque vous
pensiez obtenir l'investiture
législative sauf que bah c'est HUG
grandanson qui a été investi qui vous a
choisi comme comme suppléante à l'époque
ça a été une grosse déception pour vous
ouais c étit difficile parce que bah
parce que j'étais là au début de
l'aventure que j'ai j'ai vu ces étoiles
s'aligner avec beaucoup de surprises
hein parfois le 10 décembre 2016 la
Porte de Versailles c'était incroyable
euh et effectivement je pensais avoir
cette investiture euh le l'équipe a
choisi HUG Ranson qui est devenu
vice-président de l'Assemblée et je je
pense que bon ben voilà l'histoire a
montré 5 ans après que je pouvais y
arriver mais ça n'a pas été simple al
ben ça n'a pas été simple effectivement
on va regarder ça en détail 5 ans plus
tard rug grançon ne se représente pas
sauf que cette fois et ben c'est David
Amiel qui a été choisi à votre place euh
comment est-ce que vous expliquez qu'à
deux reprises euh on n'est pas reconnu
et récompensé votre travail sur le
terrain ça donne le sentiment que vous
êtes l'éternel Dauphine euh toujours en
deuxème position mais c'est l'histoire
de ma vie et je dis Dauphine ou dauphin
parce que vous avez eu cette phrase j'ai
toujours l'impression d'être un petit
dauphin au milieu des requins c'estàdire
que comme si vous arriviez pas bah à
vous imposer à vous placer à faire jouer
vos réseaux ça fait partie de la
politique aussi alors ouais ça fait
partie de la politique moi je sais très
bien me battre pour les autres alors là
je ne lâche rien donc donc voilà mais
c'est toujours plus difficile finalement
vous voyez quand vous êtes manager dans
une entreprise moi j'ai jamais eu de
problème àer demander pour l'équipe en
fait des rémunérations complémentaires
des augmentations de salaire pour faire
simple mais ça toujours été plus
compliqué pour moi et je pense que j'ai
j'ai eu du mal finalement à faire passer
ce que moi je pouvais apporter au sein
d'une équipe mais parce que je pense que
j'ai parfois un manque de confiance en
moi qui raisonne par rapport aussi à mon
parcour cours et je me dis bah est-ce
que c'est moi qui va faire le meilleur
job dans cette position de première
finalement Olivia Grégoire vous a prise
comme suppléante dans la circonscription
juste à côté qui a cheval sur le 15e et
le 7e arrondissement elle était ministre
avant les Législatives elle est
redevenue après vous faites donc partie
de ces suppléants qui sont devenus
députés quelques semaines après les
autres et d'ailleurs vous êtes regroupé
entre députés suppléants sur téégram
pourquoi il y a c'est difficile d'être
député suppléant moi je pense que on est
arrivé un mois après les autres et donc
cétait cétait la folie donc on est tous
placés donc sur les rangs du fond et
donc vous êtes les derniers arrivés
doncenez les plac qui rest tout en Haoui
mais ce sont de très bonnes places je
vous l'assure puisque vous avez une vue
en plus moi je suis complètement au
milieu sur l'ensemble de l'émicycle et
vous ne ratez rien et donc vous êtes
donné des conseils entre vous on se
donne des conseils entre
nous on on se motive il y a des heures
qui sont parfois difficile et puis
surtout voilà il y a une solidarité je
pense que c'est important d'avoir
l'impression de faire partie d'une
équipe dans l'équipe d'un mot vous
faites partie de ce qu'on appelle l'aile
gauche de la majorité Olivia Grégoire
elle elle était plutôt assimilée à
l'aile droite est-ce que ça peut créer
des tensions entre vous comment ça se
passe si vous prenez des des positions
différentes sur un même sujet c'est
quasiment jamais arrivé avec Olivia par
exemple au moment où on a su qu'on
allait faire équipe ensemble on s'est
dit je me souviens un après-midi on se
parlera sur le texte fin de vie parce
que le le président a pris un engagement
et il est qu'on ait en fait des idées
qui ne soient pas les mêmes et on a une
circonscription aussi Qui est qui est
très partie prenante en fait sur ce
texte là sur le reste en toute sincérité
on s'écrit très régulièrement tous les
de jours tous les TR jours on échange
sur tout un tas de choses mais pas sur
temps sur les position politique sur
immigration je lui ai dit ce que je
pensais via la tribune et l'important
c'est de la prévenir et qu'elle sache
aussi se dire bah j'ai été prévenue par
Fanta je sais ce que si je suis
interrogé parce que pour la peine elle
fait beaucoup de médias je sais aussi
com
voilà il y a un sujet qui vous tient
particulièrement à cœur c'est celui des
familles monoparentales parce que vous
avez vous-même été maire célibataire à
un moment où vous repreniez vos vos
études tout en en travaillant
aujourd'hui vous avez fait donc de ce
sujet un combat politique vous pensez
pouvoir faire adopter un un dispositif
d'aide d'ici à la fin de la législature
sur ce sujet si je reste en place il est
certain que je ferais adopter quelque
chose quoi qu'il m'en coûte qu'est-ce
qui vous aurait le plus aidé à l'époque
en tant que mer célibataire euh tout ce
qui concerne le le le système de garde
ça c'est très difficile ouais c'est le
plus dur parce que si vous voulez faire
carrière en fait mais ça nécessite du
temps on est encore dans un pays où on
estime qu'à 19h si vous êtes là c'est
très bien si à 16h30 vous êtes parti on
le voit notamment sur la population des
hommes donc en fait le système de garde
je pense qu'on peut innover on va passer
à notre quiz à présent vous allez devoir
compléter les phrases que je vais vous
proposer on y va euh faire de la
politique c'est renoncer à sa vie de
famille ouais c'est dur
il faut s'organiser mais c'est pas
évident on laisse de côté ses amis on
commence à ne plus aller au dîner plus
aller aux anniversaires donc et puis
pour les enfants moi la mienne est
grande maintenant mais ça a quand même
un impact pour mes parents avoir une
fille
députée bah je pense qu'ils sont qu'ils
sont fiers encore une fois ils ont pas
pu venir c'est un regret ils on pas pu
venir vous voir à l'assemblé non mon
père a été malade juste après il a fait
deux AVC et puis ma mère est devenue
aidante du jour au lendemain et donc bah
j'espère qu' vont pouvoir venir ce sera
pas évident mais je sais qu'ils sont
fiers mais je crois que je voudrais voir
ça dans leurs yeux et j'espère vivre ce
moment enfin si Olivia Grégoire quitte
le gouvernement que ferez-vous écoutez
j'ai la chance d'avoir un d'avoir pas
mal de choses donc pour moi donc déjà je
pourrais retourner donc dans mon ancien
jump puisque j'ai un contrat qui est
suspendu et puis après il y a plein de
d'horizons qui peuvent s'ouvrir donc il
faut juste voir les Opport
regard encore une fois les bonnes
étoiles merci beaucoup fant ber d'avoir
été l'invité de la politique et moi
merci à
[Musique]
vous I